E aí
[Música]
é o que vamos de nós a cada momento
e como nos vemos
e como nos vim
e como nos deixamos ver e o quanto somos
nós em cada imagem Nossa
a fotografia é uma das formas nos
rogamos aos outros sim um processo de
revelação do que somos e também do
quanto nos reinventamos e das diferentes
personas que Assumimos deixe-me
partilhar convosco algumas imagens que
revelam Exatamente isso o lado estético
poderoso da invenção do Imaginário do
desejo da beleza da criatividade e até
de um lado aspiracional para muitos de
nós a vontade de ter desse uma
representação assim são imagens
Poderosas
e são artistas de cinema são grandes
Produções fotográficas
o som trabalhos de cocriação entre o
fotógrafo eo fotografado e são também
pessoas com tu e eu não processo
criativo em relação elas próprias se as
memórias que a fotografia guarda são por
definição estáticas em margem fica
guardada pode ser elástica elástica
porque se reinventa elástica por cada um
de nós pode assumir diferentes
expressões posturas personagens atitudes
movimentos
Oi e esse exercício da Redenção é por
definição importante na fotografia mas
principalmente na vida e se esta
necessidade de reinvenção e de
experimentação sempre foi importante em
pleno século 21 é essencial a fotografia
tem o poder de criar uma realidade
visual que não existe aliás existe e não
existe tudo ao mesmo tempo estranho nem
por isso na fotografia e numa sessão
fotográfica de retrato tem sua
oportunidade experimentar novos ângulos
e descobrir coisas sobre si próprio que
talvez desconhecesse a beleza de uma
sessão fotográfica É permitir que vejam
lados eu que nem sabia que existia numa
sessão fotográfica pode ser o que tu
quiseres
eu fiz uma Célia
Oi e a Célia outra vez
Ah e ainda a Célia
o filme Brasília
a imagem é essencial à nossa imagem é
essencial a forma como nos apresentamos
é essencial
e não somos só nós e a forma como os
outros nos veem e forma como os avaliam
assim que nos bem sim a todos nós E
todos nós a fazemos quem consegue ser
imune as primeiras impressões mesmo que
não queiramos mesmo que às vezes até
onde viemos mesmo que eu achei errado as
primeiras impressões são naturais são
reativas são universais fundiárias que
vemos assim que olhamos para alguém pela
primeira vez é determinante na forma
como avaliamos e não vale a pena dizer
que isso não é real além da nossa
experiência empírica muitos estudos
demonstram
e quer queiramos quer não as pessoas
tomam decisões sobre nós julgam nos
cinco nos vim e mais importante ainda
isso acontece quer nos ver juntos
somente quero que seria uma fotografia
nossa
e esse vem o quê perguntou vocês tirei o
nosso nível de inteligência o nosso
estatuto socioeconómico e até as nossas
preferências sexuais e nem sequer estar
em causa se deem bem ou mal apenas
tecido em um estudo dos psicólogos
Genilson e Alexander todorov revela que
não 12º formamos uma impressão sobre
alguém que observamos com a primeira vez
e ainda mais importante que essa
primeira impressão e que isso
dificilmente muda mesmo que estejamos
depois em contacto prolongado com essas
pessoas incrível não é um outro estudo
revela que muitos momentos as primeiras
impressões são tão importantes que
chegam a colocar em causa o que sabemos
sobre as pessoas
Eu repito mesmo que saibamos alguma
informação sobre determinada pessoa essa
informação pode ser subjugada pelas
primeiras impressões pela nossa
observação e pelo julgamento associado
mas perguntam-me vocês João Estás a
dizer nos que nós não temos poder
julgamento racional e que a maior parte
das nossas decisões e impressões são
inconscientes sim e não só sim porque
são e porque sabemos por experiência
própria só por sabendo de nós e tendo
consciência das consequências que este
imediatismo julgamento pode ter podemos
usar o nosso favor
e se olharmos para o lado menos bonito
devemos ter cuidado com os nossas
primeiras impressões e julgamento
imediatos questionadas e tendo a ousadia
de ver para lá deles se olharmos para o
lado menos inquietante podemos tirar
partido desta realidade a nosso favor
e a primeira impressão é também uma
primeira relação e a pergunta é como é
que nós vamos controlar os outros
o que conexão Vamos criar com os outros
e como é que os outros se vão conectar a
nós
É sim falamos de conexão a ligação que
estabelecemos com os outros ao nível
pessoal e profissional
e acreditem a conexão é menos imediata
do que as primeiras impressões quero
dizer que podemos e devemos trabalhar
para ver como é que isso aconteça de
forma mais efetiva e eficaz com maior
resolução comer impacto
Oh e vamos até o carnes apenas No
Impacto que a imagem tem a nível
profissional no retrato profissional não
pode ser quem quer mas uma boa
fotografia pode fazer toda a diferença
na sua vida por exemplo quando vem
alguém nos no Linkedin que conexão
queria com a sua fotografia
eu pudesse escolher entre colocar no
currículo uma fotografia não de entrar
meu mal e outra em que se sente no seu
melhor qual escolheria não vamos
trabalhar todos os dias com a mesma cara
podemos estar chateados com a vida
podemos ter dormido mal
a equipe entre a importância de para lá
descer os profissionais temos de parecer
profissionais
bom e o que é um retrato profissional
podia ser apenas um retrato tirado por
um profissional mas é ver mais do que
isso o principal objetivo de um retrato
profissional é capturar uma fotografia
de alguém como se estivesse no seu
melhor dia com a sua melhor expressão
que demonstre todas as qualidades
preciso evidenciar simpatia
profissionalismo confiança e
acessibilidade é imediato não precisa
ser trabalhado precisa
e a criação de um retrato profissional é
isso mesmo uma criação aliás uma
co-criação entre o fotógrafo eo
fotografado é preciso criar uma relação
de confiança e dar espaço Porque se
houver um sorrisos Nunes e expressões
faciais verdadeiras é preciso treinar
experimentar encontrar pode seguir a
revelar o melhor no do rosto encontrar o
ângulo que irá permitir que cada um de
nós passa uma boa primeira impressão
através da fotografia
É sim Queremos ser os profissionais das
boas primeiras impressões
eu consegui mulo sempre que as fotos que
utilizamos estão bem focadas ou seja
sabemos bem qual é o seu foco seu
objetivo Não podemos continuar a ver
pessoas a fotografias em contexto
profissional olhares vazios para sempre
um pouco naturais
e o rosto com sorriso largo é muitas
vezes visto como mais amigável e
confiável na dúvida sorria e não cruze
os braços os braços cruzados sem Lisa
uma pessoa fechada muito fez emocional o
foco deverá ser sempre no rosto e Na
expressão logo não existe o problema de
saber o que fazer os braços o foco é o
presente estar no presente e criar uma
conexão
bom e como uma imagem vale mais do que
mil palavras Observe atentamente as
imagens a mesma pessoa ângulos
diferentes expressões diferentes
primeiras impressões diferentes
é sempre a mesma pessoa
é sempre a mesma pessoa imagens
completamente diferentes
e reconhecemos agora a importância da
imagem
é mas tenho ainda mais um desafio para
vocês vamos trocar de objetiva e olhar
para o rosto mais peludos
e em Portugal existem mais de 30 mil
cães à espera de adoção em Cannes e
associações procura do melhor amigo
Nunca nenhum não é sempre a primeira
opção quando se procura um cão e mesmo
que seja nem sempre nos apaixonamos à
primeira vista
e essa conexão e tal conexão não é
sempre imediata
Hum será que aqui também podemos
garantir melhores e mais emocionais
primeiras impressões
a frase será que uma fotografia pode
trazer resultados inesperados
e já é difícil contabilizar a quantidade
de pessoas que se apaixonaram por um
animal ao ver as fotografias do dia my
friend parte com vocês algumas ações que
marcaram
e a baunilha adotada por alguém q se
apaixonou quando a viu no Website do
Jimmy rende e veio de propósito a
Portugal para adotar a lessie que estava
no cantinho da milú há 11 anos e
finalmente sabe o que é ter um lar
de Camões
é o velho cãozinho
a Wig
e o ângulo em que o animal é fotografado
a proximidade do rosto iluminação a
edição é tudo pensado para causa mais
Impacto mais conexão mais empatia em que
investir fotografias porque também não
cão para adoção uma boa fotografia pode
fazer toda a diferença na sua vida
e o Be my friend é um projeto
fotográfico criado para ajudar nas
adoções através da arte da fotografia A
ideia é mostrar os animais fora do
ambiente canil como se tivesse mesmo não
estúdio fotográfico no fim importa
poucos estamos a falar de retratos de
pessoas ou animais precisamos reconhecer
que a estética é importante
nós precisamos a primeira revelar o
melhor de nós percebendo que as imagens
que transmitimos nossos próprios são
importantes podem conhecer nos nível
pessoal e a nível profissional e que não
devem ser deixadas ao acaso
e nada torna alguém mais fotogênico do
que a confiança é preciso mesmo entender
que as primeiras impressões acontecem a
todo momento mesmo que não nos
apercebemos e portanto a questão é como
tu vais levar os outros
E aí